c'est l'heure de l'épisode 6 les amis je
suis triste pourquoi parce que ça va
être la première fois qu'on fait un
début de vidéo sur the last guardian où
il ya patrick obama dont il faudra qu'on
le retrouve il avait continué sa voix
sous l'eau et nous on avait pu perdre ça
fait longtemps que j'y rajoute je te
content de rejouer à la ok on se
réveille ok on est bien on est bien
tricot et des pulls à ras du cou on
n'est pas si bien mais je sais pas du
tout où on peut aller là bas par la fin
là tout simplement
allons-y suivons le chemin et espérant
tomber j'espère qu'il va surtout rien
arriver à tricot en fait en attendant
parce que nous on est vulnérable et lui
il l'est encore plus maxi tombe sur des
gens au bouclier la c'est quoi ça
ah c'est quoi c'est quoi ce délire là un
truc qui réagit quand je suis dessus et
et là on a une armure s'entête avec de
la lumière qui sort du corps bonfanti
des lampard finalement c'est même plus
n'a rien c'est juste une vieille lampe
ah ok notre objectif la deuxième plaque
et avant il serait ce un truc
qui se passe je sais pas ce qui se passe
au plafond c'est chez basse qui se passe
assez au taz est temps on pourra
me faire écraser mon gars on va rentrer
dedans et ça va nous faire c'est tout
nouveau ça huawei l'ascenseur de
nageoires dames c'est incroyable
ces trousses d'un vieux piège à
l'arrivée ya des gardes mains c'est bon
tu avais peur mon gars je me disais dans
ça peut se terminer comme ça donc
l'appareil on active la deuxième plaque
qui se passe un truc comme ça dans les
musiques qui se met à faire monter les
marches pose à amman ont noms peuvent
pas monter les marches non tricot
ça fait bizarre qui est plus tricot ça
fait chier surtout à tanger peut pas
traverser via sa 6ème moyens assis en
équilibre
bah ouais l'autre côté bon du coup j'ai
pas trop compris le fonctionnement des
plaques mais je pense que c'est ça c'est
faux que activer les deux plaques en
même temps pour que ça active
l'ascenseur tout est là rien avait l'une
des deux qui étaient activés toute seule
mais là comme les deux sont éteintes et
ben est au coeur des tensions je ne peux
pas activer la deuxième donc on se
retrouvait dans ces décombres a
peut-être trouvé un truc a posé sur une
plaque pour qu'elles s'activent
ça lance des théories je suis sûr qu'on
va retrouver tricot en étant en
situation de faiblesse à face à des
de garde je sais pas pourquoi je
suis convaincu que c'est par là non
ok c'est bon
on grimpe tout seul okçular alba l'herbe
connais bien pouvoir atteindre espèce de
poutres qu'on a vu hop on est en haut
très bien et là on a une chaîne
ah bah faut peut-être tout simplement
monter achats auprès de la chaîne ouais
ça nous mène à une poutre hockey est ce
qu on va traire c'est ici claque
yes bon on est sur de l'herbe
on continue notre petite route on est
toujours en train de gagner en
verticalité si je puis me permettre
je crois qu'en france j'avais dit
cependant les vidéos merde c'est bon
très bien g j'avais oublié à quel point
cet enfant est fort en tout ce qui est
non
non c'est là que tricorps
non mais il va bien il va bien parce
qu'on est content mais je suis sûr qu'on
va avoir un ascenseur et tricot
oh non il est couché il est à terre non
up hockey comme ça on atterrit sur la
branche c'est quoi ça j'espère
qu'on va pas tomber aux non au
il bouge de rennes c'est patrick o
pas du tout répond
l'équipe l'as tu es tombé
elle a un masque et fâchent non
non non les trois montées au elle
a la force de tricot est là tout comme
tricot incessants c'est la même spirale
et l ajuster comme un peu plus poussée
vous avez remarqué aussi que les corps
des tricoteries s'est petit à petit dans
l'épisode
peut-être que c'est comme nous les
humains par exemple on brandit peut-être
que c'est juste leur leurs cornes qui
poussa c'est différent tiko est un
adolescent ou un enfant
oh mais c'est le moment c'est le
moment de faire ça l'est soit suspendue
à c'est mieux avec moi là d'un matin ne
faut pas que je me mets suprême pour sa
part qu'on se mettre debout
je peslerbe
ok on est bon mais et c'est chaud
et je l'avais après je suis
je suis retombé sur les images peuvent
enfin miniatures et je tricot avait une
moitié de casque en fait sur lui donc je
pense juste que c'est un animal comme
lula avec un casque et où il a dû faire
une méga chuter son casque s'est cassé
et du coup les armures ont perdu le
contrôle qu'elle avait sur lui j'ai
passé ma théorie est ok ça me va pas
passer en plus allez on y va parce là
dedans
waouh il m'a fait peur avec son
nez en le con je passe un journal et je
pense que je devais aller à gauche mais
dans le doute
thual
c'est chaud là il y avait deux choix
possibles je sais pas si j'ai pris le
moins ouais si c'est bon ça va être
quelque part en tout cas c'est mon fils
allez on y va
quelle échelle
on va faire l'échelle rapide voilà
encore une échelle patrick au mec tu
nous manques tellement elle va me suivre
longtemps la bête là tu as je suis
tellement triste pour cette baie de
monga j'ai vraiment envie que mon
instruction masque qu'elles deviennent
comme tricot une bête sage et mignonne
as well as the approach shot sur sa tête
au caire
hop hop là merci demande de rester là
allez viens viens mettre la tête dans le
trou je donne des ordres
c'est bloqué merci mon gars c'est hyper
malin ce que tu fais tu rigoles et qu
elle ait voix pour le clou en même temps
elle habitait les enragés donc là je
pense qu'il ya pas trop réfléchir je
vois on se retrouve curé remonte tout ça
ils nous surveillent d'autres encore
c'est ça ouais on arrive à la péter ok
je trouve un petit chemin on va
continuer par la voix ça c'est un
endroit bien pouvoir mettre sa tête
encore l'hôte à bannans faut qu'on aille
là en fait à faut que mme accrochée à la
grille
assez stressant cette phase achevée non
je vais aller dans les caves
ok mais ça nous a menés ok
fait vannes où il va nous acteurs
bah voila c'est direct qu'est ce qu'on
fait maintenant ouah
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire on est blessé
en plus ça ah ouais mais là on se fait
démolir ya tricot qui va arriver
peut-être à y réagir sans avoir annoncé
l'autre ces tricots cas remake
j'appelle tricot ok je m'enfuis comme ça
en faisant ça
1 on dirait c'est patrick o qui
l'appelle à citer les gardiens c'est le
gardien qui l'ont appelé mon gars
ouais des gardiens qui s'ouvre dans des
décors pour rappeler qu'au delà
je suis content de retrouver nous
a manqué moi comment tu vas tu es
beaucoup plus beau que l'otan plus si je
puis me permettre
c'est nos petites retrouvailles à dos
ouais c'est ça c'est bien moi tu peux
sniffer tout ce que tu veux je le
caresse à travailler et où tu mènes à
sortir tu peux tu peux casser cette cage
ou pas il s'en c'est ouf il sent
l'odeur comme un animal sans l'odeur
d'un autre animal quoi bomber un mec on
va essayer d'avancer
peut-être qu'un jour cette cage va se pt
non mais je pense qu'en fait il va me
permettre d'expliquer pas présente au
balattou locaux
oui c'est ça super merci mon grand allez
on y va ce parti est ce que ça passe
ouais moyens si c'est bon on passe à ses
bons chantera à s'expliquer
au teint
je passe casser cette cage mais qu'elle
est un vin c'est quoi c'est incroyable
obama cas je redescends j'ai conversé au
tricot
eh ben ça va être utile à décembre la la
la la
tin comment se fait secouer
par contre je vois du coup ils veulent
en venir avec les auront finalement on
retourne là où il y avait eu c'est les
deux plaques et je pense que ça va être
une plaque pour ce tricot une blague
pour moi là je crois qu'on est parti
dans les marches mon gars
au magic magique donc j'ai activé ça du
coup j'ai activé celui-là wesh pas trop
commun avec deux avec le métal mananjary
sur l'autre ok c'est fait et ça s'ouvre
est là qu il soit fait en premier mais
quand on sort on va sauter sur tric en
direct moga et voilà je le caresse bah
oui les retrouvailles bon gars on est
contents alors on pourrait aller main en
tricot qu'on est revenu au point de
départ mais je vois pas trop où ça peut
nous amener à tout net c'est plus que
mérité tout mettre tout ça dans la cage
où tu peux en avoir ici n'en regarde et
attend
voilà derrière l'armure fatale et
peut-être juste un mot tout pour passer
sinon bah non bah merde
peut-être qu'il faut mettre le casque
dessus pour qu'elle vienne théorie
théorie ah mais oui il y avait un casse
dans la cage
et ben voilà c'est exactement ça
j'arrive t'es con je vais te ramener un
combat rimont garbo pierce elle se
réveille on court à un bout de la map
moi aussi bien bien par là le mais c'est
qu'ils rentrent dans la cage mecs se
serait louf way déroulant voix auprès de
ico pour complot pour mon gars ok on l'a
jusque là et là oh yes on le
prend et on se casse çà va l'armure et
restent bloqués par le but c'est vrai
c'est comme dans l'épisode de la reine
il reste bloquée alors qu'il ya de 20 cm
de béton quoi du coup on voit des sorts
a fortement de rageux aller au vote
mondiale tricot tu vas être fier bah oui
tu reconnais tu es content ah bah oui ça
va du papillon ses comptes en tas c'est
quand qu'il a annoncées ou faisait puis
pluie boue plus la séquence en fait on
est parti mon grand allez je te montent
dessus je sais que j'arrange chose à
manger derrière tu fais un saut de
fouquet je m'accroche
tu peux y aller c'était un peu engourdie
peut-être voilà asie nice a maintenant
les piliers kalaba voit la direction le
pilier et on va remonter tout là-haut
grâce au pilier yes ok le suivant
parfait il se débrouille comme un chef
se dit comme on peut le faire confiance
les yeux fermés ça qui est bien hop très
très bien et hop le grand saut et on
arrive lui en était tout à l'heure
parfait tu peux tu peux venir du trou
d'où tu viens pas je pense que oui j'ai
pas su rendre une façon il peut passer
nulle part ailleurs et ziti vas tu l'as
vu cette fois tu l'as vu allez vas-y mon
grand allez on y va
hop là oui tu peux des schémas ici tu es
venu ici
super je viens pas envie qu'ils te
mettre le casque et que tu te retournes
pour moi ça me ferait mal au coeur ça
m'a brisé mon petit coeur de jeunes très
bien bouazzi je vais descendre je vais
avancer voir ce qui est à quai ce qu'on
a ici à bas à gauche c'est l'air l'air
libre il est de retour
a study bien on revient de loin
on était en cage au début de l'épisode
mon gars on est bien là on est bien par
contre si tu bah oui tu exprimes ta joie
d'être libre l'accroché à toi je sais
que tu vas faire un saut je sais je et à
chaque fois je me sens pas bien cela est
dû le fait la job migrants y est très
très mais très très très très bien je
donne tout et là oh ouais bah voila j'ai
besoin de demander tu es très très très
fort jolis tricots très beau aussi pas
tu te retournes tout seul mais il fait
tout tout seul tant que j'aime bien
quand il fait ça quand on met notre
cerveau à off pour deux minutes
dans la vidéo c'est là bas et c'est ton
dernier sou puisque après je pense que
rob plus trop m'avancer je me trompe pas
quoique je pense que là ouais ok ils
remboursent à moins de coaching
m'appuyer d'accord et bata leur tricot
c'était un sauna et manqué de faire du
rodéo sur ton dos comme ça t'en fais pas
pour moi mon gars tu vois bien se
presser tu as toi un moyen de nous
rejoindre mais que c'est sûr on continue
à là tout de suite rico là tu as pu nous
voir il ya un tournant
et voilà a très vite et qu on ne voit
déjà plus on est triste alors
qu'est ce qu'on a ici tricot claire
points comme ça ça fait mal au km 11 ans
ici on peut re rentrer dans un endroit
qui est du papillon mais pas de lamu du
vrai papillon exposées dans nature on
atterrit à ben voilà on va du louvre hop
là c'est fini de pleurer il attend
sagement allez viens avec moi je crois
qu'on peut rentrer là-dedans tricot aux
non c'est quoi ça à temps mais ça
ressemble vachement a passé le même
c'est même truc quoi tricot et va venir
là il va être mal il va être il va être
à terre pas mais tu vas tu as pété un
câble tricot je suis désolé ça je
reste à venir
hopla esquiva bah ouais super g apporte
soutien apporté à porto choisi tricot
vite c'est bon je me suis échappé parce
que là il apparaît juste à côté d'autres
clubs me défoncer en deux voilà il
valait démolir mais à s'aimer inonde
pour le calmer
merde ça la salle à part du méchant
nov
non
[Musique]
c'est moi oh
mais c'est moi et on se pose tous là à
d'accord on était obligé de se faire
capturer ça fait partie du truc
c'est intrigant qui volent non je sais
pas il ya des années
là
oh
viens boire pendant que je dors
ah non
non je vais voir partir
il va me cacher dans sa bouche
maintenant ils mangent pas une cache
dans sa bouche bée
cagim sa bouche
[Musique]
invite par d'autres
non non c'est pas mal paraître
[Musique]
non je suis libre
moi
[Applaudissements]
on avait tort
à vous
ayez recours n'est
une moto autonomie sarrabère
[Musique]
je
à
bras
[Musique]
c'est là où on s'est réveillé au tout
début du jeu avec lui ils ont attaché à
une chaîne
wima recraché
c'est là que mes tatouages sans tabac
oui je n'étais pas de parler de vouloir
des réponses et bah je crois qu'on en a
un peu là qu'elle a bâti son équipe en
amérique etc
ils viennent chercher les enfants d'un
village et que les habitants du village
voir l'enfant partir avec l'animal
ils disent que c'est un élu ça arrive
pour un plein de questions mais sans
soulève plein ou si c'est terrible mais
bon les investir dans cette zone
n'étaient pas là mais ça vous a plu
mais que là on s'approche
sérieusement de la fin du jeu
c'est bon a les atouts du projet devait
recevoir des plantes et vous via un chat
au monde pis
[Musique]